[Musik]
italien oder england vor dem em finale
im londoner wembley stadion steigt die
spannung noch zwei stunden bis zum
anpfiff streit über deutschlands corona
kurs während die einen mehr normalität
fordern sie sorgen sich andere um
mögliche ansteckungen von kindern und
jugendlichen und das weltall im
privatflieger ein britischer milliardär
hat heute seinen testflug und plant das
große geschäft mit dem weltraum
tourismus
nachrichten nicht dass leute mit
christian sieber einen guten
sonntagabend hinein und willkommen bei
uns christin ist hier für den sport an
einem besonderen tag absolut ja nach
vier wochen fußball geht es nach eher um
den titel italien und england stehen
verdient im finale ein sportliches duell
auf augenhöhe in london ist bereits
jetzt partystimmung mitten in der stadt
65.000 fans sind im wembley stadion
zugelassen
und so sieht das jetzt bereits aus in
london das ist der leicester square
die papst rechne mit einem riesenansturm
wir haben mehr dazu später in der
sendung und schalten live nach wembley
die vielen feiern besonders die
außerhalb des stadions machen kritikern
sorgen in einem land in dem trotz der
massiven verbreitung der delta variante
die meisten corona beschränkungen
aufgehoben wurden
und auch in deutschland läuft die
diskussion über den richtigen weiteren
weg aktuell meldet das
robert-koch-institut 745 kroner
neuinfektionen das sind 186 mehr als am
vergangenen sonntag
sechs weitere menschen starben innerhalb
eines tages im zusammenhang mit 19
die sieben tage instanz ist weiter
leicht gestiegen auf jetzt 6,2 britta
spiekermann über das was daraus folgt in
den stadien lassen sieg oder niederlage
den abstand deutlich schrumpfen und das
alles meist ohne masken
heute kommt deutliche kritik von der
spd-spitze generell an
großveranstaltungen risiko zulasten
jüngerer mann muss man immer daran
denken dass es eine bevölkerungsgruppe
gibt altersgruppe nämlich die noch nicht
geschützt werden können und da müssen
wir jetzt rücksicht üben solidarität
üben damit eben auch die kinder und
jugendlichen ihre chancen im herbst gut
wahrnehmen können in nordrhein westfalen
können konzerte theater
sportveranstaltungen mit hygiene
konzepten und testpflicht stattfinden
ministerpräsident laschet lockert ist
das verantwortungsvoll wir haben
lediglich für die inzidenz von 0 bis 10
also extrem niedrig
einige grundrechtseingriffe
zurückgenommen ab 10 gilt das was in
ganz deutschland liegt und ein ähnliches
modell baden württemberg hat
niedersachsen den schulen soll so
laschet mit einem aufgestockten
bund-länder-programm geholfen werden
damit luftfilter klassenräume sicherer
machen
den grünen reicht diese ansage nicht wir
brauchen dringend einen schulgipfel
damit die kinder corona sicher aber auch
regelmäßig in die schule gehen können
der druck sich auf den herbst
vorzubereiten wird größer jens spahn
will per verordnung genauer auf die
belegung von krankenhausbetten schauen
wir wollen wissen wer erkrankt und wie
gut er geschützt ist nur so können wir
zeitnah abschätzen wie hoch die
belastung für das gesundheitssystem wird
und wie gut die impfungen wirken
koinzidenz bedeutet so sparen nicht
automatisch hohe intensivbetten
belegungen das würde heißen möglicher
spielraum für längere lockerungen noch
elf wochen bis zur bundestagswahl und
den umfragen gerade mal bei 7 prozent
die linke steckt im tief aus dem will
janina wissler co vorsitzende und
spitzenkandidatin der partei heraus
führen
wie das gelingen soll aber auch was
nicht geht mit der linken erläutert sie
im zdf sommerinterview andreas künast
zwischen den wahrzeichen des
bundesdeutschen kapitalismus das erste
zdf sommerinterview der überzeugten
antikapitalisten und überzeugten
frankfurterin janine wissler
vor nicht mal fünf monaten an die
doppelspitze der linken gewählt soll die
hessische fraktionsvorsitzende die
bundes partei in die offensive bringen
vor dieser bundestagswahl stehen die
umfragen auf rekordtief es war kein
leichtes jahr für uns also gerade das
letzte jahr das kona pandemie ja wir
mussten zweimal uns vom parteitag
verschieben und damit natürlich auch die
personelle neuaufstellung aus der
personellen alt aufstellung der partei
fällt die analyse um einiges gnadenloser
aus vor allem sarah wagenknecht
kritisiert dass sich die linke zu wenig
um die sorgen der arbeiter kümmern
und zu viel um wie sie sagt
lifestyle-themen die
geschlechtergerechte sprache
ich glaube nicht dass am trainer liegt
also ich glaube man kann beides machen
wir müssen die sozialen
ungerechtigkeiten deutlich machen aber
natürlich geht es auch um eine sensible
sprache bisher kommt vom ganz linken vom
trotzkistischen flügel der partei
anders als die ko-vorsitzende handle so
lehnt sie alle auslandseinsätze ab auch
blauhelm einsätze im auftrag der uno
nicht reden wir über jeden einzelnen
einsatz und und in jedem einzelnen
einsatz muss man alternativen benennen
näher und aber ich glaube dass
grundlegende probleme sich nicht so
lösen lassen
eine regierungsbeteiligung ist wissler
nicht so wichtig wie ihr wichtigstes
wahlziel ein zweistelliges ergebnis
einfahren
das ganze sommerinterview mit janine
wissler gibt's gleich nach uns bei
berlin direkt außer dem hof zdf heute.de
und in der app wenn sich milliardäre
heute einen wettstreit liefern geht es
offenbar längst nicht mehr um schnelle
autos und tolle willen jetzt greifen
drei unternehmer quasi nach den sternen
airline besitzer richard branson und
amazon gründer jeff bezos wollen
höchstpersönlich ins all fliegen und
haben dabei natürlich auch den
lukrativen weltraumtourismus für reiche
im visier
branson ist heute gestartet wenige tage
später hebt b songs ab viel geld mit
weltraumflügen der nasa macht bereits
tesla finder elon musk aus den usa glück
war es lief alles nach plan in 15
kilometern höhe
klingt er das trägerflugzeug den
raumgleiter aus dann ging es mit
zweifacher überschallgeschwindigkeit
hoch mehr als 80 kilometer über der erde
konnten branson und seine mit
astronauten dann drei minuten
schwerelosigkeit genießen
der milliardär zeigte sich begeistert
das ist das erlebnis meines lebens ich
blicke hinunter auf diesen wunderschönen
weltraumbahnhof glückwunsch an alle die
das möglich gemacht haben
seit 17 jahren arbeitet bransons
weltraum firma an dem milliardenprojekt
bei einem unfall kam 2014 ein test pilot
ums leben
der weltraumflug seinen jugendtraum
gewesen so der 70-jährige
mein traum ist es dass junge leute sich
das genauso fasziniert anschauen wie ich
vor jahrzehnten die erste mondlandung
verfolgt habe
die premiere heute ist jedenfalls
geglückt hier am weltraumbahnhof in new
mexico sind alle erleichtert vor allem
das richard branson und seine crew
wieder sicher am boden gelandet sind
das könnte jetzt der startschuss sein
für mehr weltraumtourismus so zumindest
das versprechen der bedarf ist offenbar
groß bransons firma hat eine warteliste
mit 600 kundendienst all wollen und
dafür 215.000 euro bezahlt haben und wir
bleiben noch kurz in den usa eine
rekordverdächtige hitzewelle unter der
die menschen im westen des landes gerade
leiden temperaturen um die 50 grad
celsius dazu extreme trockenheit eine
verheerende mischung immer wieder kommt
es zu schlimmen waldbränden wir hier in
kalifornien versuche die feuer zu
löschen scheitern weil die luft so heiß
und trocken ist dass das löschwasser
sofort verdunstet tausende menschen
mussten sich in sicherheit bringen
so jetzt mal an diesem sonntagabend beim
sport christin und die fußball ja und
blickpunkt london durchweg der serbe
novak djokovic hat zum sechsten mal das
bedeutendste tennisturnier wimbledon
gewonnen
seinen insgesamt 20 grand-slam-triumph
womit er mit roger federer und rafael
nadal gleich zieht ein viersatzsieg
gegen den starken italiener matteo
bettini
die aktion des serben nach gewinn des
dritten satzes zeigt auch wie hart
umkämpft dieses finale ist für matteo
bertini ist es sein erstes endspiel bei
einem grand-slam-turnier und umso
überraschender dann couragiertes
auftreten hier der gewinn des ersten
satzes in time doch von da an spielte
novak djokovic seine routine aus und
kann nach knapp dreieinhalb stunden mit
6 7 6 4 6 4 und 6 3
seinen bereits sechsten übrigen titel
für sich verbuchen
sollte der 34 jährige auch noch die us
open im spätsommer gewinnen wäre ihm
damit der grand slam der sieg bei den
vier großen turnieren in einem jahr
gelungen
so jetzt aber zum fußball nach knapp
zwei stunden dann ist anpfiff zum finale
der em italien gegen england live im zdf
ab 20 15
oliver schmidt ist unser reporter uli
das wird wahrlich ein ganz besonderer
abend in london auf jeden fall hier die
kathedrale des fußballs das wm gestartet
ist bereit für das europäische hochamt
trotz steigender corona zahlen die
straßen sind voll das stadion
ausverkauft 64 1900 zuschauer innen und
rund 7.000 7500 mit einem herz für
italien
die schwarzmarktpreise schwindelerregend
mehrere tausend pfund werden gezahlt um
hier dabei sein zu können
denn england womöglich zum ersten mal
europameister wird 55 jahre nach dem wm
triumph 1966 gegner damals deutschland
heute italien seit 33 spielen
ungeschlagen ein duell sportlich auf
augenhöhe
ausgang offen gänsehaut atmosphäre ist
garantiert und die vielen dank gehirn
dich nachher als reporter bei der copa
américa steht der sieger bereits fest
argentinien ist südamerika meister durch
das 1 0 gegen gastgeber brasilien in rio
erzielt di maria den entscheidenden
treffer zum ersten koffer sich seit 93
zugleich der erste große titel mit der
nationalen
für lionel messi die argentinischen fans
fielen danach zu hause
logischerweise wie gewohnt in einen
kollektiven freudentaumel
ein emotionaler tag ja mal sehen wir
heute noch taumelt heute haben vielen
herzlichen dank christian schauen wir
uns jetzt noch das wetter an morgen
trocken und häufig sonnig nur einzelne
schauer im nordosten nachmittags im
westen schauer und einzelne kräftige
gewitter das ganze bei 23 bis 30 grad so
von uns sagen wir danke fürs interesse
wir nehmen sie auch mit in die kommende
woche ab morgen bis dann aber erst ihnen
allen einen angenehmen abend
das heute-journal in der fussball
halbzeitpause und jetzt geht es hier
erst mal weiter mit dem zdf
sommerinterviews